you don't say squeeze aujourd'hui on se
retrouve non pas source de forest mais
sur ce soit honnête dit voilà c'est un
jeu qui ressemble d'ailleurs the forest
ça fait plaisir ça fait longtemps qu'on
n'avait pas fait de forêt star game ok
on n'a pas un avion avec des belles
grosses turbulences a fait plaisir et a
fait marquer un objectif je crois je
dois me servir un martini non non ce pet
ou quoi que ce possible où on est en
plein milieu de l'eau voilà on peut le
voir ici présente n'est pas du tout
rassurant en passant aux abats voilà
martini en faisant un clic droit center
de tutoriels je vois bing fr martinique
qu'est-ce qui se passe et là je dois
prendre mon feu et je dois aux [ __ ] a
peut-être fait un [ __ ] de cocktails
d'entrée de jeu j'adore sujet vraiment
et je peux le bois ensuite boire les
flammes carolos dessus de l'eau s'il ya
un problème chose de l'avion je tombe
dans l'eau vous me prendrez pour sa
blague à pick up e
et voilà on a vu un martini quand on a
bu le verre avec apparemment retourne
s'asseoir
ça va être un long vol ouais un bon gros
crash c'est surtout vrai quand dans un
[ __ ] de simulateurs en fait tout est
faux tout est du fait que je vous ai
pris en flag ces caméras cachées bordel
real elle va exploser
attention de 20 en un c'est l'avant
c'est carrément la morale assez glauque
j'ai horreur de ça [ __ ] plus j'ai peur
de l'avion moi de vous dire à personne
et on se réveille sous les mers oui j'ai
la bouée de sauvetage
et alors maintenant qu'est ce qui se
passe on s'enfuit comme ça et bien sûr
il ya 1000 milles requins autour de nous
c'est évident entre eux et c'est donc au
sort comme le sèche-cheveux dans demain
ne faut pas le lendemain sur cette bouée
toujours bien gonflés allez on y va dans
la boisson au merde je ne peux plus
faire ça c'est quoi ce bruit ok je me
cache mon cas je me cache le gast a eu
un bruit de tonnerre au vote
robert redon
mais c'est bon je suis donc voilà je me
suis en effet trampoline
allez allez on y va mais dames emilie
camp mais c'est pas possible
regardez regardez le lui s'exciter du
manioc est allé barre toi moi je te met
un coup de rame dans le nez on va vite
aller sur la plage arrêtez de faire les
malins
comment sonne l'os sur vannes tos et
aucun survivant je suis seul [ __ ]
c'est super joli rock comme maroc non
interdit ça fait bien angers un couteau
j'ai un feu et c'est que le caillou je
te va péter l'arbre aux crabes je peux
le prendre
non j'ai pas d'ardeur crop c'est le
crabe que j'aime
oh [ __ ] on s'est tous bien frisbee
bordel ça vient des crabes ya un mec qui
m'envoie les objets quand je les pros
vous avez regardé au persil michel il
grandit plus je le court plus je grandis
c'est quoi cette île celle où je peux le
prendre
oh [ __ ] on peut faire ça et comme la
corde à sauter comme ça ouais
ouais c'est génial au début ça on a fait
un mort et on attend le mec
ok j'arrête m'évade su ménage pas c'est
pas le monde lâche et imbécile et une
torche
oh [ __ ] j'aime pas ça et c'est la
course d'albanov phoques alors du coup
je connais pas de merde qu'est -ce que
ça non la console et obtient son
intéresse pas je disais ce n'est pas du
tout de dow kraft
donc c'est pas du tout ce qui est
possible de faire en dehors de couper
ces [ __ ] de pamiers qui grandissent
qu'on les coupe qui on à véritable
direction et là normalement on peut
faire voilà on peut faire un bruit de
facebook aux mondiaux une hache mon gars
est ce qu'on peut lui [ __ ] le feu
non j'ai pas d'artifices sur cette
[ __ ] deal ok voilà je sens qu'ici on
être notre bonheur bordel alors petit
plainte vient à moi plantes à patates
alors l'âge ou faire des petits trucs de
folie au bois pas et ça fait faute
copains
et si on y ajoute logiquement pas mal de
pierres pas plus que ça apparemment
merde je fais amastaibou ils ont tout
niké [ __ ] je mets quoi sur mon cv mois
après ça bordel on apprend de sucre avec
nous vous allez voir il va nous servir à
rien mais ça peut être drôle parce que
d'un coup hop soudainement lancer de
crabes mais kraft est chiant tu fais du
muguet [ __ ] regardez ils essaient de
partir unique ou deux mais tu vas de
d'un jeu bordel mais qu'est ce que c'est
que ça mais oui mais c'est un un creuset
de spirent un cru de spirent pardon qui
permet notamment entre autres deux on va
prendre la sardine regarder elle est
belle elle est belle chaque toile est
minuscule quoi c'est ridicule je vais
remplir 2ème % ton estomac est ce qu'on
peut faire cuire un [ __ ] de grave si
je pose dessus aux écrits faisant nous
entende et les parents revient lacrabe
lascia croustilles et alessio potes à
côté même si j'étais invisible
je te vois tu es suis fort bien là je te
dis en fait ils essaient de s'enfuir du
coup ce qui sont pas décédées ah ben
c'est bon on était cuit on riait jaune
le manger ouais à merde ça m'a
empoisonné à cet été il était peut-être
pas bah non je n'ai mangé cru et ben
c'est pas mal est ce qu'on est en train
de faire un on peut grimper en haut d'un
arbre pour choper les cocos nom aussi
fantastique cg non par contre pour
descendre comment ça se passe je repère
la cible ni vu ni connu je t'ai eue
petites sardines mais la blague c'est
que je n'ai pas de place pour toi dans
mon inventaire
oh mon dieu c'est pas de vous les a
sauvés c'est trop tard c'est moi qui
l'ait au [ __ ] qu'on peut faire une
fondation comme ça c'est très bien c'est
la maison à l'heure actuelle non mon
marteau au ma vie et passionnante a pas
bête comme ça après je peux mettre des
murs comme c'est carrément bien ce
qu'ont fait lens débrouille bien là le
toit et les faits mais
artisanale quoi où je peux le mettre le
mur s'il vous plaît au peuple un feu de
camp on va le mettre juste là bien à
côté de l'eau de sorte à ce qu'ils
soient et à un coup sûr dans une minute
waouh au monde j'ai une montre donc la
nuit tombe il est 21h je dois manger
quelque chose at on déjà tu te calmes
parce que ans mais j'ai rien à tanger vu
ses escaliers avant parce que c'est plus
important aux alors ça alors là quand
même s'il vous plaît la petite entrée
vraiment belle on peut inviter quelqu'un
là on est vraiment bien et manque plus
qu'un lit on va faire un lit à prier
pourquoi ne propose pas il ya tout ce
qu'il faut si tu manges un peu de coco
ça va ça de faire du bien mon gars non
non pourquoi j'appelle mis ce qu'il
fallait par terre pour faire le pic a
chassé le crabe et c'est chelou que je
fasse ça en vidéo oui oui mais voilà
jean sixième fois notre petite vidéo sur
ce point m d'ils j'espère que vous a plu
c'est le cas n'hésitez pas aimer les
vidéos comme d'habitude et surtout si
vous voulez qu'on fasse un bug comme
pour the forest vue classe le jeu en
action anticipé il y aura toutes les
deux semaines toutes les semaines je
sais pas des mises à jour pourquoi ne
pas faire des vidéos à chaque importante
mise à jour voilà puisque là c'est vrai
qu'il ya pas grand chose on a vite fait
le tour
franchement content du cadre avoir
refait une vidéo sur un jeu du genre ça
faisait un peu de temps et puis ça
laisse vraiment place à la créativité
j'aime beaucoup
aède survivants comme ça devoir se
débrouiller on les appelle indigènes
mais bon il ya des ricains encore merci
à vous regarder on se retrouve très vite
dans une nouvelle vidéo vous connaissez
le blabla à tout le monde
à